and we are right now joined by both
magnus carlsen and
lavon ironian and i'll ask you first
magnus how do you feel after this crazy
game
um well first of all i think it
got sort of appropriate
results um in the end
obviously it's very very disappointing
to have um
stop giving away a lead um i mean
i don't think i i deserve to to win the
match
um today but yeah especially
after i managed to
to come back in the game it's really
disappointing to
to blow it all again and levon
in in that game with so little time
on the clock you did make a comeback and
you did win it how are you able to do it
i just got lucky i think we
exchanged luck i i
uh plundered in the third game
and magnus blundered back in the fourth
game
but generally i think it was more or
less an even match
and magnus uh you're saying if you know
you you
kind of deserve to to lose that final uh
game
how are you feeling about the result
here you're tied in the first semi-final
match
no it's it's a little bit um
like on the first day against uh
raja that i didn't feel like i i played
so well so in that sense
2-2 is um it's okay uh and i'll just
have to try and do
do better to tomorrow but i mean
regardless of how it
how it happens uh giving up um a lead in
the last game is
is is disappointing and uh well lavon we
were
super enthusiastic about that first game
as well you came out
very aggressive what was your plan
heading into the semi-final against
magnus
i you know every time i play against
magnus i
try to do my best this time i was trying
to have
some fun and
while trying to do my best well of
course
i took my chances and uh
of course my play in the first game is
very dupes but
i said to myself why not i can play one
game like that
all right it seems maybe we lost contact
with magnus but lauren how are you
feeling
about a tie in the first match i think
it's a it's a fair result i can't
say that i was playing brilliantly i was
very slow with important moments
so yeah i have to work on my speed and
just on other
aspects you know just to get the
positions that
i like and magnus doesn't
easier than that yeah well i believe
that all right lavon we wish you the
best of luck tomorrow thank you for
joining us
thank you very much guys